[Music]
fine wood furniture is a fixture of
homes throughout the world but getting
the raw material to make it doesn't
always mean
raiding our forests for some
manufacturers it's now coming from
urban areas where downed trees and old
buildings might otherwise end up in
landfills
and along with helping the environment
it is also creating jobs in
neighborhoods that need them errol
barnett has more
at this baltimore warehouse the lumber
is anything but run-of-the-mill
a lot of this lumber was harvested
around the civil war and a lot of the
the trees that were turned into this
lumber really started growing probably
in the 1500s
the antique yellow pine was saved from
crumbling row homes like these
so it has a grain that you wouldn't find
today it has a color that you wouldn't
find today
and it really just as importantly to us
it has a story
and we can be able to kind of hold on to
that little bit of history
max pollock is the founder of brick and
board a company that sells
reclaimed wood and other salvage
material in baltimore
a city with an estimated sixteen
thousand vacant and abandoned properties
for five years you've been a part of
what people describe as the urban
lumber movement what is it and how do
you see
yourself fitting into it it refers to
both lumber that's harvested from
buildings that would otherwise be
discarded and sent to a landfill and it
also refers to
capturing material that falls during
storms woodworkers across the country
are building the movement
but pollock says there's more work to be
done if you were to pull
100 people who are working in the
reclaimed wood field the truth is is
that a lot of them look like me they're
white guys with beards and with flannel
shirts but there really isn't any reason
why that should be the case it's always
been important for us to
try to democratize these skills a little
bit um to try to take people who may not
have had
the opportunity to go to shop class or
may not have had the opportunity
to apprentice with the carpenter and
teach them about the material teach them
about milling this stuff
so that they can create a career out of
it like 21 year old dante godwin who's
worked here for about a year and a half
he appreciates the opportunity he tells
me in a city with an unemployment rate
that usually tracks a few points higher
than the national average
it's not that easy getting opportunities
i was lucky i had mentors to give me i
wouldn't knew about this opportunity
if it weren't for them so even in
baltimore
with a high black population and a rich
history
it's very difficult for young black men
to get started
yes most definitely that's why more
black man is in the streets than having
a job
brick and board is just one of the
private partners in the urban wood
project
a collaboration between the city of
baltimore the usda forest service and
others
the hope is that salvaging wood can
revitalize the city
this used to be abandoned row homes
it's now a park exactly right it's a
park you can't hear these birds and
residents comment on that
co-leader of the urban wood project is
sarah hines of the usda forest service
she wants to help other cities replicate
what she calls
an urban wood economy zip codes like
this and similar have
high rates of unemployment high rates of
poverty
high rates of incarceration underlying
health issues
this project can ameliorate a lot of
that by
thinking about ways to employ people
give people opportunities
avoid waste and plant trees in places
that desperately
need them i don't think most people
realize that
logs in a landfill are actually a bad
thing yeah if you think about a tree
it's sequestering or capturing carbon so
that's co2 that's in the air
and it stores it in the body of the tree
and so when that tree is removed and
it's decomposing it releases all of that
co2
back into the atmosphere contributing
obviously to climate change
jennifer seliga leads the urban wood
rescue in sacramento which is funded in
part by a grant by the california
department of forestry and fire
protection
she says her organization has
sequestered six thousand
seven hundred and seventy metric tons of
carbon
that's equal to about seven hundred
thirty one thousand gallons of gas
we're able to divert logs that would
normally go to the landfill
into our yard and then get them back out
into the community
but seliga admits this process isn't
easy
it's a long endeavor from when the log
is taken down to when it becomes a piece
of furniture
and it can be very costly building out
partnerships and building that community
is just really important to success
one of those partnerships is with
minnesota-based room and board
a furniture company that is also part of
the urban wood project
turning reclaimed wood from baltimore
sacramento detroit and minneapolis
into sustainable furniture and a core we
have one planet
so all of us need to look at not only as
leaders but as individuals to say how
can we make a difference
room and board president and ceo bruce
champeau says
his company has an environmental and
social responsibility
it's a combination of using those
materials and creating jobs for people
that didn't have an opportunity so it's
more than just about
role resources absolutely the social
aspect of it
is equally as important and i think when
you take those two things and you
combine them
that's where it becomes something really
magical remodeling the way we care
for each other for cbs this morning
saturday
errol barnett baltimore that's that
both ends it looks great it looks great
it helps the environment and it helps
people you know i've gone through
many abandoned houses and it was the
thing that i said to myself
where is all of this material going and
so now
there's a place for it to go i'm just so
excited about this great story
vidya and ariel errol just great story